miami
they are the nobles i
present to you the largest cuba in the
world the hipster
you cannot be thinking about school and the
princess of a piece of news
they know no limits it is seen that the
account statements of my children need
more maturity those children but they are about to
receive  a lesson was canceled in milan
and my blog they canceled everything
[Music]
can you explain to me why they are
taking everything from us as if we were in
venezuela because they discovered a fraud
[Music]
and if we turn ourselves in
now they will have to get
[Music]
what they have never had
[Applause] I'll
work
if you don't pass your ticket, I
'm not going to go out like this beast of leftovers
credit cards
[Music]
the pesero of the fight is a pirate peace
this more for the pumas so
hair beads heart but  that yes
no
nobilis until the end this looks like
thailand
we the nobles I am not leaving here
until the two thousand pesos are there